l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessimo
video sono bravi j
oggi siamo su playing the field complex
fling playing che significa ragazzi fuga
dal complesso è una dei videogame tipo
quelli con il big man non so se vi
ricordate e niente cominciamo perché
ancora non ho visto la mazza è
nuovissima avevo uscito adesso l'ho
fatto ho fatto io eccola ristic mani è
sempre lui ma questo è quello di karate
kid lo scanning nottur ies criminosa che
la madonna bichir frumentario ma
[ __ ] scatterà in tre secondi ma
come ha fatto a catturarmi non mi
ricordavo come finiva volo i tuoi
so.in.so fa devo stare qua ciao zia
questa è vero io sempre culo ciò con
letizia in york siamo già partiti
ragazzi non si sa perché posso fare
allora bus up ma non posso rimorchiarla
tizia sensei sta uscendo questo e per
caricarlo questo e per aspettare il
trasferimento questo non so fingersi
morto finale prova a fingermi morto
ragazzi is grigorij e non yuan hendry
isde ci ha creduto ma come fai a crazy
ed efficienti ok
ma no vabbè che l'hanno buttato giù ma è
così che si trattano i morti deficiente
ma è pronta aspettiamo il trasferimento
allora siamo qui e qui tanto c'è la
tizia vorrei dov'è andata grazie grazie
io sono a posto che le porte arto sonic
pulse la laser una finta influenza io
proverei la finta influenza ragazzi in
via sotto san donà armate si mia madre
faceva uguale quando ce vò la febbre
dovevo andare a scuola uguale a salve mi
hanno chiuso in una stanza con tutti gli
effetti quarantena del trasporto eco
kikuchi facciamo cookie che non mi
mangio un biscotto certamente qualcuno
ha voglia di spiegare no no cioè va bene
così no teletrasporto the trasporto
valori prende questi oggetti non mai
capito o a posto siamo sulla luna vabbè
mi bastava fuori dall'edificio un finale
degno dei film di zac efron laser plain
ci manca ragazzi sono più questo show o
dio ce l'ho fatta era quello giusto
ragazzi è grazie a cassano provati tutti
chiedo al [ __ ] che ho schiacciato
cuffie ero io quello che ho schiacciato
usiamo le cuffie perché le cuffie sono
sempre il mio amico quello dell'altro
dell'altro episodio quindi mi puoi
venire a salvare
ok quindi devo provare a uscire insomma
chiaro che c'è gente per poi cosa fai
una mensa perfetto bando shine earth
plans grande zio perfetto ti diciamo
subito residuo ragazza e mais amia già
visto non ci credo
eccolo qua ci siamo quasi ragazzi devo
solo beccare il soffitto che li edifici
addosso charles vini e ricotte rosnay
facciamo sai perché sono un cecchino
professionista ma no guarda dove vai
cast di riscattare a lei peso mi piace
rom e allora non sono io quello
ricordatevi ma in chiedere supporto da
cecchino a uno che guida un elicottero
ormai fanno non fare così perché sei un
[ __ ] facciamo ciao sospetto che fa
così la facciamo
oddio è il resto è storia legali il
resto ve lo immaginate tutti ora la mia
faccia come terrorizzata torino ci sono
schiantati tute e una triste è una
lacrima strappa storia mini elicottero
ma anche solo questo ragazzi perché devo
andare fin là sopra una famiglia sono
duemila scala ma va veramente sei un
genio addirittura col bazooka ma devo
togliere assolutamente tizio col bazooka
perché ecco chi erano ciao sono parigi
grande inizia che atterraggio perfetto
degno del parcheggio di una donna zio
complimenti ce l'ho fatta serio pubblico
così ho vinto così a caso seme senza il
mio amico charles non ci avrei mai fatto
la cosa ragazzi ho completato la prima
parte che ci sono un sacro e vedere se
riesco a farle altre tipo bus tap
io a rimorchio così comunque quando sono
per strada li conoscete questo segno
perché io lo faccio per i macchia c'era
una botola sul soffitto sono dei geni
quelli che non il carcerato veramente
sei riuscita a livello certo ci credo
subito sapesse tipo portato su rally è
bella è la grafica figurati siamo a me
la porto su ciarelli regola xbox
e dunque facciamo ragazzi alla vista di
stylist la mia lista
[Musica]
ma perché ma perché è lì scappa scappa
si chiamano complimenti boutros facciamo
business in dieci punti ragazzi a testa
a testa tolga il ragazzo alto con
l'abito perché certamente un ragazzo
così non viene viene considerato per
niente il prigioniero non vedo come un
ragazzo alto dovrebbe essere qui è
infatti la crockett mi stavo chiedendo
anch'io si cronista del dow era giusto
questo alla fine che era effettivamente
il più geniale siamo arrivati qui
ragazzi quindi devo andare di sopra
quindi judo traumi butti su col judo
grande zia complimenti a posto gravi
thor gravi thor straniero o mio dio che
figata è già un passo avanti però dà
forza usa la forza come star wars
siamo una forza
a 9 poteva essere la regina del mondo
facendo così come dio infatti tutti noi
siamo rimasti noi abbiamo sempre nel
capra anzi perfetto un'arma testa io la
granata tu l'hai mica quante
combinazioni oddio si è fermato così
ok allora niente granata e tool taser
brucia che usassero forse elettricità
più granata e crisi exclusion appare in
trio che dai cro aifo teaser di sparare
a lui ha preso la mia faccia ne ho in
mente sabbia fa ho sparato a caso già
abbiamo fatto bene prendiamo i caffè a
io devo prendere il caffè bayern a
passiamo senza farci notare senza farvi
notare ragazzi a questi sono quelli che
scappano
no non siamo guardie allora rubagli il
cappello anno lancia il cappello di
riscontri che abbiamo
abbiamo curato l'oro invece che noi
fantastico
che casino a perché abbiamo liberato
tutti ma fantastico come ti permetti di
toccarmi la ragazza lurido pezzo di
merda disney bene papà io ho ucciso
anche lei troppo potenza ragazzi ma
farli incazzare make a face certamente
in una situazione del genere cosa che
puoi fare ovvio nel caffè i siti che
devo dire lasciamo usciamo
non facciamoci domande e usciamo come
fosse uscire ragazzi dalla cosa da con
una moto o con il camion e allora
dall'arga la decisione ma non c'è un
calcio alla sede serio ma chi è che ha
fatto il buco
siete dei deficienti e allora andiamo
con la moto la vittima di mafia
ancora tu no la tizia se n'è andata non
annozero di domani
ragazzi ma lasciato qui qualche al nido
pezzo di di baffo non c'e non ci posso
credere un attimo pensato i miei mi ha
abbandonato che l'abbia fatta bellis ho
anche trovato la gnocca ragazzi meglio
di così non poteva andare d'accordo
ragazzi con clou di questo primo
episodio di come cazzo si chiamava
feeling field complex perché ci sono un
sacco di altri di altre cose che puoi
fare durante il gioco è quindi parola
parte ii dove proverò gli altri finali
vedrà ghazi spero che vi sia piaciuto ci
vediamo nel prossimo episodio a sé
perché mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook della ragazza